let's start with the tonsil drama when
did you get some kind of idea that he
was going to be falling that this video
and text exchange was out there well
then I'm on you know we have the inside
said in the outside set so I'm on the
outside set and the first round started
and also night they're getting some text
messages from from scouting buddies with
team saying have you seen this video
have you seen this video and they're
sending me links to the video well i'm
paranoid i'm always thinking okay you
never know when you're Mike's going to
be hot or when you know something could
happen they could come to you or me
sitting or watch the video on my phone
when that happens so I can see the
picture of it which obviously did not
look good but I hadn't heard anything in
my ear for a while because they're
communicating to the insights that so I
can't hear what they're saying to those
guys and then finally he just started
dropping and I think ian rapoport came
on and talked about it and then
eventually the producers gotten our ears
on our set hey we're going to come to
you come to you guys for a character
discussion and then we got a chance to
kind to go on talk about a little bit
all right you were a scout your job is
to you know assess talent but it is
there also as a scout you have to look
for this personal side of a player how
involved you are you with that as a
scout no question in every single school
that you go on that's one of the things
you're hunting for nice to find out
about drug use and you'll find out about
positive test now the interesting thing
is Laremy Tunsil never tested positive
it'll mess and i can tell you i mean
look if if you took every player off of
your draft board that had tested
positive forget like you've heard that
he smoked that they say that he knows
i'm talking about positive test at the
school I mean you'd probably wipe out a
quarter of your board if not more so to
me this whole thing last night was not
about the crime it was about the it was
about the timing of it obviously in the
images of it but if this would if this
would have happened save this thing
would have happened a week ago and teams
had time to kind of do your homework I
think this I don't think you would seem
rough always dolphins well why did he
drop is it because he he's there with
the video of him smoking pot or is it
that he took money
so I don't think the money thing has
anything to do with it I don't think
that's I think teams don't don't care
about that i would say the just the
timing when you're in that draft room
then and you got your owner in there and
a man you gotta you gotta say okay this
is the guy hey this is going to be our
press conference we're going to be
holding up the security tomorrow at our
facility and we're going to have to feel
the million questions about this whole
thing I mean it just I think teams
looked at that and sane I just don't
want to do it I don't want to do it and
you know I think if you know if this kid
can can stay out of trouble but dolphins
I think I'm the best player in the
entire draft really I leave my number
one player in the draft and gift it is
ultra talented but you're also at that
position and offensive lineman and I
don't know if that does that carry
obviously it doesn't carry the same
weight if this was a quarterback because
you don't want your quarterback you know
making those kind of decisions but as an
offensive lineman can you get away with
it a little bit more than you can at
other positions well we always would say
that character this stuff concerns you
the more you get to the middle of the
field and I know as maybe that's not
fair but you know corners and wide
receivers you know you're going to be a
little bit more forgiving you talk about
quarterback centers you know kind of
those leadership positions or you're
making all the calls and all those
things you know you'd be more concerned
where he's playing a tackle i would say
kind of falls in that middle ground
there's not ideal you don't you don't
want your first-round pick a team being
with this woman's you right before you
pick him I mean that's the matter what
position he is but he's not yet what I
said being on there was look this is not
the only guy that is a participated in
that activity and I would venture a
guess or probably a couple picked ahead
of it but have done the same thing he's
Daniel Jeremiah the NFL Network UCLA
linebacker Myles jack how far does he go
there's a year's name today tonight oh
yeah I'll be shocked here's my peers my
predicament I'll say that the Titans
have three second round picks I mean if
ever there was a team to go ahead and
say hey let's just take a shot here this
guy's this guy's I think the second best
player in the draft if he's healthy so
to me I think the Titans you look at
them and I wouldn't be surprised if you
saw a team trade up for the top of this
round and go get them the oddest
or move yesterday was one to me it was
San Francisco coming back in for four
guard and John Garnett agree I I I just
don't get it i mean look he's he's a I
thought he was a third-round type player
on my phone you know like it it we often
be wrong with my phone blew up some
friends around like saying what are they
doing uh what you have to sync now Chip
Kelly lasted in a silly their guards
were terrible and uh and you could say
maybe that had some impact on him losing
his job so he was definitely going to
try and look at that area you like what
the Broncos did with Paxton Lynch I do i
do I I like it as long as there are you
know they've come up with a game plan
for him as I say yeah we don't need you
to start game one here I mean let's just
come in here and develop you and spend
the time to do this right but he's got a
tremendous amount of ability and I
thoughtful for where they got him I
think it's a good fit he fifth grade in
that Kubiak system everybody always told
me my buddies in Baltimore how much
Kubiak just love coaching Joe Flacco I
mean even loved him what he can do with
his arm and his kind of skill set their
arm strength wise and now he's got a guy
that has some of those same traits what
what drama do you expect today in the
second round you got some probably
another run on quarterbacks Derrick
Henry is going to be there we talked
about Myles Jack what's the big question
mark or interesting point I mean how
many how many millions of Ohio State and
Alabama players are going to get [ __ ]
maybe Tamela it's just like it's I think
every other pic in the strap went to
Miami to Clemson Ohio State or Alabama
and we're going to see a bunch more in
the next couple rounds but Myles Jack is
the big storyline where she go great
stuff thank you good luck tonight doing
Daniel we appreciate it thanks damn
ticket right the Dan Patrick show
weekday mornings on audience